OF LYING, POMPOSITY, SMUGNESS,
GROUPTHINK.
>> Sean: A BUSY NEWS NIGHT.
WE BEGIN WITH THE FOX NEWS
ALERT.
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS
NOW PAVED THE WAY FOR FORMER
DEPUTY FBI DIRECTOR
ANDREW MCCABE TO POSSIBLY BE
INDICTED.
TONIGHT, FOX NEWS HAS LEARNED
FEDERAL PROSECUTORS RECOMMENDED
MOVING FORWARD WITH CRIMINAL
CHARGES AGAINST McCABE AFTER
HIS LAST MINUTE APPEAL WAS
OFFICIALLY REJECTED.
McCABE WAS ONE OF THE SECOND
HIGHEST RANKING MEMBERS OF THE
FBI.
THE INTERIM DIRECTOR AFTER
JIM COMEY WAS FIRED AND McCABE
WAS JIM COMEY'S RIGHT-HAND MAN
AND HE WAS TRUSTED TO OVERSEE
SOME OF THE HIGHEST PROFILE
CASES IN THE BUREAU AND IN THE
COUNTRY.
IN 2018 ANDREW MCCABE WAS FIRED.
WHY?
FOR LYING AND FOR LEAKING.
THE DOJ INSPECTOR GENERAL ISSUED
A SEETHING REBUKE OF THE FIRING
OF THE DIRECTOR AND IT WAS
DETERMINED THAT HE LACKED
CANDOR.
THAT IS WHAT WAS DETERMINED.
THEN ANDREW MCCABE LACKED CANDOR
INCLUDING UNDER OATH ON MULTIPLE
OCCASIONS IN CONNECTION WITH
DESCRIBING HIS CONNECTION TO
DISCLOSURE TO
"THE WALL STREET JOURNAL."
THE IG ALSO ACCUSED McCABE OF
LEAKING SENSITIVE INFORMATION TO
THE PRESS AND BLAMING THE LEAKS
ON OTHER PEOPLE, INCLUDING
"McCABE VIOLATED THE FBI AND
THE DEPARTMENT'S MEDIA POLICY
AND CONSTITUTED MISCONDUCT."
AS YOU CAN SEE, McCABE'S
CHARACTER IS ANYTHING BUT
STERLING.
A PERFECT GUY FOR FAKE NEWS CNN.
HE ALSO PLAYED A VITAL ROLE IN
THE FRAUD AGAINST CARTER PAGE,
PROVING WARRANTS THAT RELIED ON
THE DIRTY DOSSIER.
McCABE INFAMOUSLY SAYING NO
FISA WARRANT.
HE TOLD THE COMMITTEE, NO
SURVEILLANCE WARRANT.
WOULD'VE BEEN SOUGHT FROM THE
FISA COURT WITHOUT THE
STEELE DOSSIER INFORMATION.
LATER THE FBI FOUND OUT NONE OF
IT WAS TRUE.
OVER 90% PROVED FALSE.
THEY HAVE BEEN WARNED OF A
MULTIPLE GOVERNMENT AGENCIES BY
MANY HIGH-RANKING OFFICIALS.
THEY WERE ALSO WARNED ABOUT
USING THAT DOSSIER BY AT LEAST
ONE FOREIGN GOVERNMENT.
HIS SO-CALLED INTELLIGENCE WAS
UNRELIABLE, NOT VERIFIED,
RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION."
, "THE NEW YORK TIMES," LIKELY
FROM THE BEGINNING.
BOUGHT AND PAID FOR BY HILLARY.
THAT IS TRUE.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" IS RIGHT,
LIKELY RUSSIAN DISINFORMATION
FROM THE BEGINNING.
THAT WOULD MEAN THAT RUSSIA AND
VLADIMIR PUTIN WANTED HILLARY TO
WIN.
HE TESTIFIED UNDER OATH THAT HE
HAS NO IDEA IF ANY OF THE
CONTENTS ARE TRUE.
WHEN THE FBI TO GET AROUND TO
TRYING TO VERIFY, THEY CONCLUDED
WE CAN'T FIND ANYTHING TRUE
HERE.
THEY WERE ABLE TO PROVE UNDER
90% OF IT.
THREE WARRANTS OF THE FOUR HE
SIGNED A SAID IT WAS TRUE AND
ACCURATE.
AT THE TOP OF THE FISA WARRANT
IS HAS VERIFIED.
THAT MAKES HIS PREMEDITATED ON
THE PFIZER CORD.
THEY WERE BORN, HILLARY PAID FOR
IT AND IT WASN'T VERIFIED.
NONE OF THAT SEEM TO MATTER.
McCABE LIKE HIS BOSS JIM COMEY
HATED DONALD TRUMP.
REPORTING TO THE FORMER FBI
COUNCIL JAMES BAKER, McCABE
WAS A DEAD ABOUT THE IDEA,
SURREPTITIOUSLY REPORTING
THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND MAKING
THE CASE THAT TRUMP SHOULD BE
REMOVED FROM OFFICE.
ROD ROSENSTEIN WAS SERIOUS ABOUT
THE WIRE AND OTHERS SERIOUS
ABOUT INVOKING THE 25TH
AMENDMENT.
MY SOURCES TELLING ME McCABE
COULD FACE CRIMINAL CHARGES BUT
A GRAND JURY WILL BE CONVENED,
TEN DAYS, SEVEN, TEN, 14 DAYS.
WE WILL WAIT AND SEE.
BUT I WANT TO BE VERY CLEAR.
I WANT ANDREW MCCABE TO KNOW
THIS.
OH, YEAH, THE LAWYER FOR
STORMY DANIELS, I GIVE HIM THE
BENEFIT OF THE DOUBT.
WE LIVE IN A COUNTRY WHERE
ACCUSATIONS AGAINST ANYBODY,
EVEN FROM THE DOJ
INSPECTOR GENERAL AND FORMER
COLLEAGUES OF THE FBI, YEAH,
THEY ARE INCREDIBLY, AREN'T
THEY?
BUT EVERYBODY DESERVES THE
PRESUMPTION OF INNOCENCE.
INNOCENT UNTIL PROVEN GUILTY AND
I WILL NOT DEVIATE FROM THAT.
IT LOOKS BAD.
IT LOOKS LIKE McCABE WILL FACE
JUST AS VERY SOON.